okay we have to deal today with what is
unfortunately an increasingly repeated
conspiracy theory about Joe Biden and
Ukraine that spreading as a result of
the recent new Trump collusion
allegation which is that Donald Trump is
withholding hundreds of millions of
dollars in aid from Ukraine until such
time that Ukraine decides to help Trump
smear Joe Biden in order to help him win
Trump that is in the 2020 election and
the reason that I have to do this is in
part because some of the mainstream
outlets that have reported this like the
New York Times in the Washington Post
didn't properly debunk the conspiracy
theory and it's getting even more oxygen
now the other important thing to know is
that the new conspiracy theory about Joe
Biden is not new this is something that
far-right websites have been pushing for
a while now but it has recently exploded
so let's get into it
the idea is Joe Biden in a completely
corrupt crony istic Act went to Kiev
Ukraine and threatened to withhold a
billion dollars in loan guarantees
because a company that his son hunter
Biden is associated with was being
investigated by the Ukrainian chief
product prosecutor Victor Shogun now if
you don't look beyond that one-line
conspiracy theory it is very easy to
fall for it because it's true that Joe
Biden went to Kiev in 2015 it's true
that Joe Biden was involved in
discussions related to the actions of
the chief prosecutor it's true that Joe
Biden was one of the people that
threatened to withhold loan guarantees
but unfortunately or fortunately
depending on who you are and what your
priorities are this lacks incredibly
important context let's start by looking
at this video that many of the
conspiracy theorists are claiming is
proof of everything that I just told you
check it out a smoking gun of sorts they
say about this video I I was not I i but
it just happened to be that was the
assignment I got I I got all the good
ones and so I got Ukraine and I remember
going over convincing our team our
others to convince you know that we
should be providing for loan guarantees
and I went over I guess the 12th 13th
time to Kiev and and I was going
supposed to announce that there was
another billion dollar loan guarantee
and I had gotten a commitment from
poroshenko and from yachts and hook that
they would take action against the state
prosecutor and they didn't so they said
they had it they were walking out to
press kind of said no I said I'm not
gonna or we're not gonna give you the
billion dollars they said you have no
authority you're not the president the
president said I said call him I said
I'm telling you're not getting a billion
dollars I said you're not getting a
billion I'm gonna be leaving here I
think it was about six hours I looked I
said we're leaving in six hours if the
prosecutors not fired you're not getting
the money Oh son of a [ __ ] got fired
and they put in place someone who was
solid that is their smoking gun or
smoking gun to use the vocabulary of the
current president so let me talk about
context we often hear from people who
are like doing something wrong or saying
something wrong and they have to
apologize they will sometimes say oh no
no no what I said was taken out of
context and often it makes no sense like
in a lot of these situations there is no
possible context that would change the
meaning of what was said unless the
context was they said right before what
I'm about to say is a total joke and I
don't mean it right like that the whole
context argument Falls very flat in this
case Joe Biden was one of many people
involved in an international coalition
that was investigating corruption and
embezzlement and misconduct in Ukraine
involving the chief prosecutor Joe Biden
ended up as a point man for this
multinational effort and many countries
had already been asking for the
dismissal of the Ukrainian chief
prosecutor months before Joe Biden even
became the point man and again this got
some pickup and right-wing media but it
had never really taken off and now we
find out that Rudy Giuliani is Donald
Trump's henchmen he's going to Ukraine
and pushing them to get this Biden smear
going and as time goes the allegations
about Joe Biden become
more outrageous for example there's a
version of this conspiracy that Biden
personally was blackmailing Ukrainian
leadership into getting rid of the chief
prosecutor merely to derail the
investigation into this company with
which Joe Biden's
son is associated a Ukrainian gas
company
only the most myopic limited
understanding of what happened could
even possibly get you to that conclusion
and of course when Donald Trump has an
actual new scandal on his hands
involving Ukraine that he's withholding
two hundred and fifty million dollars in
aid unless Ukraine smears Biden it's an
environment that is ripe for counter
conspiracies like this one about Joe
Biden now I want to be really clear this
is not a defense of Joe Biden's policy
this is not a endorsement of Joe Biden's
presidential candidacy this is not a
denial that Joe Biden as vice president
of the United States for eight years was
part of the status quo center-left
establishment that we are trying to
replace with something more progressive
in 2020 this is not a defense of any
particular campaign position of Joe
Biden I'm merely telling you that the
conspiracy theory that Donald Trump and
Rudy Giuliani and right-wing media is
alleging exists is flat-out false and
it's quite frankly ridiculous and
actually it's so ridiculous that even
Fox News hosts are challenging it on fox
news broadcasts I will tell you about
that later on in the program we'll take
a quick break make sure you're following
the show on instagram at david pakman
show and while you're there follow me on
instagram at david pakman